what if you want to come home and argue
do you want to come home and have a girl
that didn't cook you dinner because
she's only thinking about herself and do
you care if she's a virgin if she's
selfish and argumentative so you're
virgin it just doesn't count like it's
like all the value that you had to a guy
is gone he'll go he'll take he'll take
the only fan model that's been with
everybody before he takes your selfish
argumentative ass and what you'll do is
you'll go to the market and say I'm a
virgin and I think I deserve new prices
and on the outside guys are like yeah
here let me let me check my wallet but
then when they did the test drive they
look at the car when they really inspect
if they see